you know how sometimes you go to bake a
cake but your bananas have all gone
rotten your utensils have rusted you
trip and pour all of your baking soda
into the vinegar jug and then your oven
explodes my friend you and your chemical
reactions have fallen victim to enthalpy
and entropy and boy are they forces to
be reckoned with
now your reactants are all products so
what are these keywords and what's their
big idea let's start with enthalpy an
increase or decrease of energy during a
chemical reaction every molecule has a
certain amount of chemical potential
energy stored within the bonds between
its atoms chemicals with more energy are
less stable and thus more likely to
react let's visualize the energy flow in
a reaction the combustion of hydrogen
and oxygen by playing a round of crazy
golf our goal is to get a ball the
reactant of a small rise and down the
other much steeper slope where the hill
goes up we need to add energy to the
ball and where it goes down the ball
releases energy into its surroundings
the hole represents the product or
result of the reaction when the reaction
period ends the ball is inside the hole
and we have our product water this like
when our oven exploded is an exothermic
reaction meaning that the chemicals
final energy is less than its starting
energy and the difference has been added
to the surrounding environment as light
and heat we can also play out the
opposite type of reaction an endothermic
reaction where the final energy is
greater than the starting energy that's
what we were trying to achieve by baking
our cake the added heat from the oven
would change the chemical structure of
the proteins in the eggs and various
compounds in the butter
so that's enthalpy as you might suspect
exothermic reactions are more likely to
happen than endothermic ones because
they require less energy to occur but
there's another independent factor that
can make reactions happen entropy
entropy measures a chemicals randomness
here's an ax norm
pyramid of golf balls it's ordered
structure means it has low entropy
however when it collapses we have chaos
everywhere balls bouncing high and wide
so much so that some even go over the
hill this shift to instability or higher
entropy can allow reactions to happen as
with the golf balls in actual chemicals
this transition from structure to
disorder get some reactants past the
hump and lets them start a reaction you
can see both enthalpy and entropy at
play when you go to light a campfire to
cook dinner your match adds enough
energy to activate the exothermic
reaction of combustion converting the
high energy combustible material in the
wood to lower energy carbon dioxide and
water entropy also increases and helps
the reaction along because the neat
organized log of wood is now converted
into randomly moving water vapor and
carbon dioxide the energy shed by this
exothermic reaction powers the
endothermic reaction of cooking your
dinner Bon Appetit
you